hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that comes as a suggestion
from a subscriber also from the Tata
steel Masters Edition I didn't cover it
while it was uh while it was happening
it's Arjun erigga easy I believe it's
the penultimate round or maybe the round
before that uh I'm just gonna check I
don't want to trick you guys uh yeah
from round 12 so from the penultimatron
maxulu with the white pieces and uh
Arjun irrigation with black uh really a
wild attacking game that
um uh well one player definitely takes
advantage of but there was a moment
during the game where everything could
have been prevented uh you guys will
help the the losing side uh try try to
avert that but uh in the game it did not
happen so let's dive straight into it uh
Parham with the white pieces opens with
D4 we have Knight to F6 C for G6 Knights
to C3 uh and D5 uh Arjun goes for the
groomfield defense with Knight to F3 uh
three nights variation Bishop to G7 and
now many moves are possible here and
many moves have been played here
numerous times like C captures on D5
Queen B3 Bishop to G5 Bishop to F4 uh
all of these very popular E3 like any
move you you play here with white is
basically Theory but Parham goes for H3
and it's a very very rare move uh that
almost looks like he's giving up a Tempo
uh but I mean probably he had something
in mind as he he prepared it for this
game it is classical chess and okay uh
here origin just castles we have C
captures on the five Knight captures in
Ponte for like you would have against a
normal groomfeld Knight captures in C3 B
captors and pawn to C5 so everything
absolutely the same Bishop to E2 and now
Knight to C6 in black with the standard
pressure on that D4 pawn and white
looking forward to advancing the pawn to
D5 at some point maybe so Bishop to E3 C
capture C three characters and queen to
A5 with check and now Bishop back to D2
you already see that something very
weird is happening here but okay Bishop
to D2 and now Queen to A3 and although
white would really want to play D5 it's
kind of a problem because the Rook is
still on A1 but that's exactly what
Parham prepared for this game he plays
Rook to sorry not that uh he plays Pawn
to D5 uh and uh he offers the full uh
The Exchange on A1 and Arjun does not go
for that if you go for this for example
Bishop captures Queen captures your
knight is attacked you have to move the
Knight somewhere you can't go for this
the queen covers those squares you have
to play something like Knight to d8 then
Parham controls this diagonal the the
dark Square Bishop is no more uh maybe
you can open up the H file which would
be deadly deadly for black but you don't
even have to do that you could just
castle and then play uh with a strong
Center and with this beautiful control
like at some point the E5 D6 will create
a pass Pawn for white you have the
bishop pair I mean you're probably going
to put a rook on D1 push that pawn and
life is good for white so Arjun doesn't
want to have anything to do with this he
instead moves the Knight Knight to E5
and now uh Parham castles with Bishop to
D7 and now Rook to B1 putting pressure
on the B7 pawn and Bishop to A4 attacks
parham's queen honey on the one Queen to
E1 and now the question is how do you uh
play this uh the the position the
position has been reached before uh but
uh uh it uh went a very very different
way here one of the nicer moves you
could play is Knight captures on F3 and
I'm just gonna show it for example
characters captures and Bishop to C2 you
attack the rook and it looks like a
wonderful idea what's uh what's
happening here with Bishop to D3 The
Rook here is is kind of in a bad spot
but you're gonna play Rook the B4 and
now okay uh Bishop to D3 for the moment
does nothing you can just defend but
what you can play is Queen captures an
A2 or rather what you cannot play
because now Bishop to C3 and even though
uh uh black did grab another Pawn black
has the two connected passports on the
queen side white will trade off the
Bishops the dark Square Bishop will not
be you know harassing white any longer
and you will play E5 D6 create a past
pawn and your Pawn should be much faster
than Black's Queen Side Pawn so that's
the idea Arjun doesn't like this he
plays Knight to D3 instead and it is now
as of move 16 that we have a completely
new game so Bishop captures Queen
captures and now Bishop to G5 Parham
puts pressure on the E7 pawn and if he
can gobble that up then he will have a
pass to D Pawn so Rook after E8 and now
Queen to B4 even though Rook captures on
B7 looks really awesome it's a very
tricky line if Rook captures on B7 then
look at this bishop B5 and now how do
you prevent Queen captures on F1 uh
Bishop captures on E7 and now after
Queen captures an F1 Queen captures
Bishop captures you're gonna play King
captors and okay you grab some material
but look at this beauty beautiful deep
Pawn you do not want to play against
that it's okay after Rook after E8 we
have Queen to B4 now putting pressure on
the bishop and pawn to B5 uh Arjun plays
this very very loudly he wants to play
A5 next kick away the queen then
continue pushing his Queen side pawns uh
Rook beat the C1 even though you could
play Bishop capture 77 and create a past
Pawn right away he first goes for Rook
to C1 he wants activity above all he
wants to put the Rook on C7 so A5
attacks the queen we have Queen to C5
and now Queen captures an E4 so he gives
up even this beautiful Central Pawn to
play Rook F to E1 uh Parham just going
for for activity uh and then you know
everything should uh should be uh well
the position should play itself but
we'll see what happens Queen to five by
Arjun and now Pawn to G4 attacking the
Queen Once Again Queen to C8 and now
Bishop captures an E7 and the past Pawn
has been created so what can Arjun do of
course he can trade Queens uh but he
starts pushing B4 he says if you want to
trade let's trade everything on C8 but
he doesn't Queen back to E3 now D6 is
coming so Queen to B7 puts pressure on
the pawn and pawn to D6 with Rook 8 the
C8 offering a rook trade now Knight to
G5 as The Rook is no longer on f8 the F7
square is uh fairly weak and you could
attack it with a move like Queen F4 so
here Rook captures on C1 Rook captures
and now Queen to D5 are taking care of
uh
that F7 weakness uh Queen to F4 and now
we have Queen captures on A2 you could
play something in between like maybe H6
kick away tonight but Arjun says no need
for that Queen cap percentage you know
he can start pushing his best B Pawn uh
we have rooked the C4 now cutting off
the Queen's defense of the F7 Pawn now
Queen captures is definitely a threat
and the way to play this is to play F6
but it looks it looks ugly I mean not
just because you can already start
capturing but because you can even play
Knight E4 and now black is just not in a
great spot uh sadly for black this is
Black's best hope of defending this
position uh Queen captures Rook is
impossible just Knight captures with
Chuck loses the queen uh so you know you
have to you have to play some like Queen
day one check and then bring the queen
to E5 and hope you survive but okay that
was not played in the game in the game
Ponte F5 was played and this just gives
Parham a bit too much he plays G
captures on F5 Ponte H6 and now just
Pawn on the F6 he is allowing H captors
and G5 because he wants to play F7 with
check and okay it's the only move that
Arjun has H capture Sun G5 F7 with check
King to H7 and now F captures an E8
bringing another queen into the game and
parting with the queen on F4 so G
captures an F4 and here comes Queen to
F7 and this is a beautiful beautiful
position uh because
um uh well for one uh you are
threatening many things like you could
uh start advancing your your passport
okay the bishop is covering this D7 but
it's something black will have to worry
about for the rest of the game however
there's the immediate threat of Bishop
to F6 which will create the thread of
Unstoppable Checkmate and it's not easy
to get out of this there is one way and
black can survive this although he has
to play a series of very very precise
moves so feel free to pause the video
and try to save this game for Arjun
while I give you a couple of seconds
foreign
this incredible idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is uh not Bishop to E8 what was played
in the game but in fact it's Queen to A1
with check and now after King to G2 just
Bishop to B3 that's the the star move
and it seems like everything is the same
but it's not you can no longer Play
Bishop to F6 the queen covers that
square now we will see Queen captures on
F4 Bishop captures on C4 and now Queen
to H4 check it looks like it's still
gonna be impossible to defend but you
have Bishop to H6 and now after Queen
captures on C4 you will play Queen to E5
very important move you don't allow the
White Queen to go behind the pass pawn
and also you don't allow D7 because
Queen captures on E7 so here look at
this queen D3 now prepares to push the
pawn now Bishop to G5 again stopping the
advancement because if you push now
Bishop captures and yes you can bring a
Queen into the game but just Bishop
captures Queen captures in B3 and it
will be black who will be winning this
game so that's uh not gonna happen so
what you will have to do after Bishop to
G5 is go Queen to G3 uh or for a queen
trade and now it doesn't really matter
what you play with Bishop to F4 you're
just gonna play Queen to F3 and if Queen
to F5 now you're gonna play Queen to D1
I put the queen behind the pass Pawn but
now Queen D7 you stop the advancement of
the pawn and that's pretty much it so
that's what you should play and
congratulations to everyone who found
this unfortunately for Arjun he did not
find it during the game he played Bishop
to E8 which is also a fine idea but it
loses to a very uh specific idea that
Parham had in mind and that is uh after
Bishop T8 Queen captures an F4 Now The
Rook is defended uh and uh Arjun can
play B3 but now Pawn to D7 and what do
you play here if you don't capture just
the eight Queen uh so here Bishop
captures on D7 now no longer black
controls the F7 Square Queen back to F7
again threatening Bishop F6 to go for
checkmate and even worse if you play B2
then Rook to H4 is mate in one so you
have to be careful so Queen to A1 check
Arjun now plays it but a few moves too
late with King to G2 and now uh well not
not a lot of moves you can play he tries
Bishop captures on H3 which is a fine
idea because if you capture on H3 then
look at this queen to H1 checking the G3
and the black now has a Perpetual if
King to F3 Queen to H1 check if you go
further then even B2 is possible and now
it's white who will have to be careful
because if Bishop to F6 now you have
Queen to H6 check plus you defend
Checkmate and after King to E2 or
wherever you bring another queen into
the game and even though a rook to H4 is
a possibility it doesn't matter Queen to
B5 check now with two queens black will
have no problems keeping at least a
Perpetual against the white king but
even though this was move 39
plays the correct move after Bishop
captures an H3 he just moves the king
king to H2 and now there is simply
nothing for Arjun uh that can be done
here he played Queen to E5 check but now
King captures on H3 and now it's very
much different Queen to F5 with check he
offers a queen trade but the resulting
end game is lost for him G Queen
captures G captures we have Rook to C7
and now King to G6 you have to get out
of the out of the way otherwise you're
just going to lose the bishop and the
bishop will be covering the B2 Square so
King G6 now Bishop to A3 and now Bishop
to E5 attacks The Rook but it doesn't
matter white is just upper full Rook
Rook the C5 was played Bishop to D4 and
now Rook captures an A5 we have Bishop
captures and F2 and Rook the B5 and he
was in this position animal 47 that
Arjun ergasi resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
The Rook is now behind the past Pawn
it's on the light Square you're just
gonna capture it you're up a full Rook
of course completely winning so crazy a
crazy game as the one would expect
both Parham and Arjun are very very
creative players but here after this
queen to F7 move which is uh pretty
crazy and it even it even invites Bishop
to B3 which we haven't discussed but now
of course Bishop to F6 as in other
variation just wins the game for Whitey
it doesn't matter that you've basically
invited the black to Royal pinu but it
it doesn't work so yeah after Queen to
F7 he had one chance of of delivering
this check to cover the the dark swears
and the bishop and G7 but uh he missed
it it was already move 35 I imagine he
was under time pressure and he missed it
with with Bishop to E8 but yeah crazy
game uh very nicely done by by Parham he
comes up on top and he takes a full
point and he had a great finish to the
tournament he won uh the last three
against he played he won all three uh so
very very impressive stuff by him but
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and that you were able to
find this pause the video moment idea
it's not an easy one to spot but
hopefully you you able to do it and it
you know it not only improved your game
but also your your day so yeah once
again hope you enjoyed it I would like
to thank
and Edwin Freeman for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day